ainsi la partie du jamais vu un truc
dans un taxi ou dans un über ou un truc
dans un tenant alors je suis tombé sur
un type dans un bear way qui était en
fête qui était je pense qu'ils offraient
à huy est en fait au départ ils parlent
autour brouillonne au fresnoy oui mais
je pense qu'en fait il avait vraiment un
maladie mentale le pauvre il a commencé
à faire il faut passer il a commencé à
parler normalement oui je lui ai répondu
que après la changer de voie et il m'a
dit ouais mais bon alors tu es comprend
donc là j'ai cru qu'en fait c'était une
blague dont je me suis mise à rire vous
me connaissez je ris assez facilement
mais elle a pris une troisième voie non
hélas janadi et laïta dis attention
plus ça va plus ça va aller vite
attention à ce que vous êtes prêts les
gars
[Applaudissements]
du coup j'ai dit que ton jeu
finalement je vais changer de
destination je vais m'arrêter là au feu
et en fait il n'a pas voulu le type n'a
pas voulu il m'a dit non et avec une
avec la première fois que m'a dit non
d'accord l'adresse c'est celle là on va
aller là d'accord et donc là j'ai dit
pas d'accord
chez vous oui en rien de très excitant
sympa ça au début de la prise de
l'assemblée ne sont pas idiots
oui en effet parce que oui et derrière
notre éducation suis allé dans un bain
karachi alors qu'elle est temps de le
prêter ensuite plus eu peur je vous
repose le dire et les mots quel rythme
et pour les deux candidats il à l'onu
tient jeudi
alors un jour le taxi me propose d'avoir
des pur sang ni % de réduction sur la
course global mais en contrepartie je
dois m'arrêter
il doit s'arrêter un fast food à pour
aller récupérer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais pas compris c'est qu'en réalité
il faisait de la livraison en plus
d'être tableau
le gars m'a expulsé lui taxi parce que
j'ai fait comme un pari passé leur vie à
droite à gauche plein droit connaît la
route et je vais parler en anglais en
était à londres
il m'a dit monsieur ça ne se fait pas il
m'a corée du taxi et s'il vous plaît est
ce qu on a un cas une bonne histoire
c'est tout ce que tout le monde elle ne
manque pas grand chose
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout dit mais cette quête d'un nom
mais c'est beau c'est maxime beaumont il
va rentrer n'avait alors j'avais une
dette très vite qu il n'y a pas tués par
un taxi alors il n'est pas retenu par un
taxi pas tout faire non j'ai rencontré
des gens alors tout mais pas dans un
taxi alors est très courte anecdotes
rivoli bac je monte dans le taxi
judy boulogne s'il vous plaît il m'a dit
non je peux pas de sac et tu dégages
voilà le court c'est la plus con c'est
comme voilà évidemment bisous aux frères
en parlant de cheveux pas de sac et non
mais pardon mais tu sais qu'on va dans
la même salle de sport que ce monsieur
nantes malick ba ouai mais qu'on ne se
voit jamais non mais parce que cette
personne passe devant tout le monde et
va s'entraîner dans une pièce secrète
vraie ville on s'arrête on ne se voit
jamais alors que nous on te voit passer
et mali qui me fait des textos me dire
le conte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]